ils sont maliens sénégalais congolais
guinéen ses compagnons d'infortuné leur
espoir d'une vie meilleure se sont
échoués dans ce conteneur après avoir
atteint les côtes de l'île de lesbos
ils sont une trentaine à se partager
c'est une pièce de choc est brutal ne
l'avons plus ou partir y aller ce culte
on ne peut pas rester chez nous ce
nouveau lui vont me tuer notre viande
devant j donc on est obligé de fuir mais
des fêtes combien nairobi 6 et u c'est
du cauchemar dès qu'on arrive on
n'imaginait pas que c'était comme ça
l'europe sinon on allait préférer des
restes et ils vont me tuer si nous là
bas
vaut mieux qu est devenu mourens en
europe l'incité la désolation la
désolation on se trouve à chaque détour
du camp de maria dans les déchets entre
mêler aux déjections humaines qui
s'accumulent partout dans le froid dont
on ne se protège jamais tout à fait sans
électricité dans les démangeaisons
provoquée par les puces de lits dans les
maladies comme la méningite qui se
propage chez les enfants je vais même
pas imaginé cela parce que nous on
écoute à l'europe via des droits de
l'homme qu'est ce que je vois ici c'est
différent tu fuis problème dans ton pays
c'était il ya six mois sont arrivées sur
l'île de lesbos
il n'avait que 17 ans sans papiers pour
le prouver on n'a pas cru dit il il
s'est retrouvé en prison comme la
majorité des hommes qui sont arrivés
seuls ici déjà cet incident est là-bas
plaisait fois deux fois trois fois
il est là bas si tu avais la main de
votre contrat moi je m'étais laissé les
passeurs qui l'ont mis sur un bateau de
fortune pour la traversée depuis la
turquie dit il lyon fait croire qu'au
bout du périlleux voyage en mer egée
c'est une vie sans tracas qui
l'attendait
ries tueur soins de santé une éducation
tout ce dont il rêvait au lieu de ça ils
se retrouvent avec la faim et la peur au
ventre
la nuit tombée ils n'osent plus sortir
du conteneur qui l'héberge
les attaques au couteau sont fréquentes
il y a trois semaines d'elvis attendait
un ami quand un homme derrière lui s'est
mise à hurler de douleur il venait
d'être poignardé
je regarde son visage et voir ces noirs
africains
je lui demandai anglais qui me dit que
j'ai commencé à pleurer parce que je
vois les centrales essor comme ça j'ai
commencé à créer demandait jean de la
mennais hôpital mais malheureusement il
est demandé mais les mois depuis le
début de l'année nous avons eu plusieurs
attaques au couteau
deux d'entre elles ont été fatales 2 qui
impliquait des enfants une fille de 17
ans qui était dans un état critique
un garçon de 15 ans seul a été poignardé
il lui aussi dans un état critique
les gens sont frustrés angoissé et ils
ont peur
le camp d'accueil de mots rien ne
devrait pas abriter plus de 3000
personnes pour un court séjour
mais ce sont dix neuf mille demandeurs
d'asile qui s'y entassent
ils y sont bloquées pendant des mois
certains pendant plus d'un an il ya le
campement officiel
est ce qu'on appelle ici la jungle les
campements que les réfugiés bricole eux
mêmes dans les oliveraies voisine nasri
ni sa famille était déjà réfugié en iran
mais pour ces hasards à venus
d'afghanistan c'était une vie sont
perspectives à la jeune femme ou
eichmann la famille entière a tout
investi pour changer son sort et
chercher de l'aide pour sa tante qui ne
parlent plus depuis que ses parents ont
été tués sous ses yeux
chez de jeunes spectateurs et quand elle
ne parlait pas du tout mais son état
s'est détérioré en arrivant ici avant l
arrivée à les seuls à la toilette
mais même ça et ne peut plus le faire
cet endroit est sûre publie mes cases
d'expression surtout h 30 est fait chez
venture et se fâche quand il entend le
bruit des enfants qui jouent ils y ont
donné des médicaments pour dormir et
sites où ils disent qu'il n'y a rien à
faire mais je ne crois pas la science de
nos jours à progresser peut-être que sur
l'île ils n'ont pas de médecin pour elle
c'est comme pour lui la clé lui c'est
amir
il a dix ans le fils de son ami un petit
bonhomme qui était auparavant plein de
vie et de promesses mais il est resté
lourdement handicapée à la suite d'une
encéphalites infectieuses
son père l'a abandonné sa mère souffre
de dépression wolof
ma vie est détruite ici je suis enceinte
d'environ trois mois et les ventes tôt
je veux bâtir une situation pour que mon
bébé qu il ou elle ait une vie paisible
et c'est mon droit
ces droits de chacun d'aspirer à une vie
paisible mais je crois qu'elle monde
entier perçoit les afghans autrement
mort
noah
avec un énorme et il est plus que
probable que l'enfant de nasrin viendra
gonfler la population de mineurs en
attente à moria les enfants représentent
plus de la moitié de la population du
camp 40% d'entre eux ont moins de 12 ans
une situation intenable dit le haut
commissariat aux réfugiés qui implore la
grèce d'aller de l'avant en toute
urgence
avec son plan de relocalisation sur le
continent des demandeurs d'asile en
attente
il devrait déjà quitté par milliers ce
qui est loin d'être le cas
mais la grèce ne peut pas tout faire
seul oui ce n est pas la grèce portent
une responsabilité disproportionnée des
communautés sur les îles en particulier
subissent une pression énorme
ils ont dû subir cette situation côté
des réfugiés pendant des années
maintenant ils sont frustrés et veulent
des solutions
alors l'europe doit ouvrir des centres
de reliquats lisation maintenant on
pourrait commencer avec les enfants nous
avons eu milliers d'enfants non
accompagnés à moria ils sont seuls ils
naviguent dans un environnement complexe
et risquée
les pays européens doivent faire une
place à ses enfants arthur 2 go
si tu n'as pas prêt nourrir quelqu'un
laisse ses portes ouvertes en précédant
cette brosse là nous sommes des nous
sommes des humains comme tout le monde
pour qu'un homme est naissant dans cette
grossesse pour me garder ses cinq sens
que ça revient
[Applaudissements]
sept-îles ils ne l'ont pas choisi pas
plus que la grèce il croyait franchir la
porte de l'europe
il pensait toucher incertaine état de
grâce mais vu d'ici le continent
semblent tout aussi matérielles que ce
dieu qui l'implorent de les aider à
traverser cet enfer qui lui est bien
réel